おお来
たここか真っ暗だ
な斜め左方向です
うわあ何にも見え
ないこんばんははめち
ですはいまたまたやってきました心霊
スポットに来ており
ます九州編はいついにですね九州の方に越
させていただきました今日来てるのは長崎
県の心霊スポットでおそらく長崎県で1番
やばいと言われている心霊スポットに来て
おりますで今回ですねえっと1人と言い
たいところなんですけれども僕とえっと
マネージャーさんの2人でこの心霊
スポットに来ており
ますあ
怖いなんかその今日イベントあって
イベントのスタッフの方とかにその今俺
いるところのこと聞くとマジですかみたい
なそこ結構本当にやばいですよっていうの
なんか何人か言っててこの長崎に住んで
いらっしゃる方からも
かなりそこ本当にやばいですよって言われ
てるようなガチな場所なので結構緊張して
おりますでは早速今日行くところ説明し
ます今回行く心霊スポットは
原城跡という場所になりますま原条って
いうお城があった場所なんでしょうねそこ
の跡地の方に今から行きたいと思いますで
何がやばいかって言われているとま色々
あるんですけれども大昔に島原のランと
いうちょっと有名なラ戦があってそこで
処刑された3万7千円もの人々の怨念が今
も残っておりその霊が出るともうびっくり
する数の霊がこの跡地にいるということで
でさらにえ有名な天草史郎天草史郎の霊も
出ると言われているし写真を撮ると武士の
霊が
映るどこからともなく血の匂いや声がする
肩が急に重くなり気分が悪くなるといった
症状も出ると言われてます腹上跡の石を
持って帰ると光熱が出るバカ持って帰り
ませんそんなものは未だに地中から人骨が
発見されることが
あるという情報がバーっとありますねいや
ちょっとね普通なんか心霊スポットで事件
がありましたとかこういう事故がありまし
たとか色々聞きますけど3万7千円の霊は
ねちょっと桁が違いすぎ
て結構本当に怖いですねこういう噂があ
るっていうのといやもう何が一番怖かっ
たかってその現地の人がえ原条あですか
みたいなそこガチですよて言われたのが
結構なんか印象に残っててあそんな怖いん
だって
[音楽]
いうただ僕疲れないらしいんではい最近の
のバさんに見てもらっ画見ましたがリンク
貼っときますあの僕ですね心霊スポと言っ
ても普通の人間よりも取りつかれにくい
なんかその霊がつけにくい体勢らしいので
多分僕は大丈夫ですだどっちかと言と一緒
に来てるマネージャーさんが心配ですすい
ませんでした僕は大丈夫なんですけど
ちょっとこの彼がどうなるかがすごい心配
なんですけれどもまそこは気にせず行こう
と思いますま笑い事じゃなく本当に長崎
トップの心霊スポットだと言われているの
で早速行ってみたいと思いますでは行って
き
ます
[拍手]
マネージャーのロビンさんですよろしくお
願いしますお願いしますロビンさんは霊感
とかありますか僕はない
ですはず
です僕はないです何かあるとしたら多分
ロミンさんですすいませんでしたいや
さ行き
ましょうなんせ風がないですね
全く寒い
そして11
月なので当たり前なんだろう
けどなんか
すごいやっぱ白跡ってだけでなんか石が
詰まれてる感じ
が
おここに原条の無料案内所があります総合
案内所夜の店とかここで教えてくれるん
ですかここって普段あれですよね世界遺産
ですよねそうですそんな場所が心霊
スポットと言われているのかまけどなんか
髪人みたいなとこありますよねきっとうわ
怖えうわ苦のモニュメントがあるって言っ
てるこっちですよね
多分というより多分ここ道路ずっと行っ
ちゃうんであそこから中中に入ってく感じ
だと思うんですよねあオッケーオッケです
了解
ですこれ余登っていいですかねいや多分
ダメだと思います
あここから
かここから登るんだ
多分キって言いませんでし
たちょマジで俺の耳がバグってるだけです
多分多分ままだ大丈夫まだ大丈夫ですよね
ですよねさすがにわ見てください早速早速
いますいますって言うとダメですけどお
さんがいます
ね
よし行きましょう
かはい世界分解遺産に登録されています
原城跡いやあうわめっちゃ開けてるな
すごい本当に白跡って感じがあります
ねいや静かだ
なあ音なった瞬間マジで分かりますね
確じゃ行きましょう登りますここですよね
きっと行き
ますお蔵
さん
こんばんはうわなんか結構道
が白跡って
感じいや静かすぎません風がひつもない木
全く揺れてないもんゼ
もういや開けてるな
めっちゃ開けてますね本当になんか白跡
って感じ
の石とかの残り方がして
ますそこなんかあるしなんかって言うと
失礼ですけどちょっとぐるっと行ってみ
ましょうか
とりあえずこういう俺めっちゃ嫌な体験し
たことあって愛知と静岡の間かなのな山で
霊スポットと言われてるとこ行ったこと
あるんですけどこういう風全くなかった時
に突然木が揺れ始めた時があっ
て普通
に怖かったですうわあ白トっ
ぽい丸いですねあの石あそこの分かり
ますい妖怪メダルのお墓です行き
ましょう
なんか黒いものがあるこれ行ってみていい
です
か失礼し
ます
[音楽]
よいしょ花城VRストリートミュージアム
ビューポイント
[音楽]
虎口VRのなんかビューポイントらしい
ですえロビさんどうしよう俺あの霊媒さん
に霊感ない言れてからなんか何にも怖く
なくなっちゃいまし
た余裕ですかじゃあもしかしてあの正直
言っていいですかめちゃ余裕ですなんなら
歴史ある場所なんだぐらいの感じで今い
ますだ耐えか
これたえあるかな開けすぎててすごいすよ
ね本当
にうんなんか言ってますいや本当に
なんか寒い
ロミさん寒くないですかタンクトップです
けどいや行かれてますよね俺そしたら当ら
ちゃんと服切られてましたよかったです
よかったですあびっくりしましたタンク
トップの霊かと思いましたえ監視カメラ
ある監視カメラありますじゃこれ不侵入し
たやついたら
もう即逮捕すねさすがにしっかりしてる
などんどん上に行きたいと思います開け
てるなめっちゃ開けてます
ここ足元
が結構草
っぽいあそこ
かあそこ結構なんか
でかいうわめっちゃ急ですです気をつけて
くださいこれ
は落ちとく
か受験生の代わり
に
[音楽]
うわあお墓っぽいなあうん
多分昔に作られたんだろうな結構薄れて
ますね文字がでもなんかすごい目立つとこ
にありましたよね
これなんか大事そうな気がする
なちょどんどん奥行ってみましょうわ
なんかちょっと歩けそうな場所が出てき
たんああめっちゃ白跡っぽいなめっちゃ白
跡
っぽい
ええ
なんか最後のもんだったっぽいです
ねわあすごいなな本当におろがあったん
だろうなここら辺いや広い
[音楽]
なあここもうてっぺんぽくないです
か長上っぽいですよ
[音楽]
ねあやっぱ本丸跡みたい1番大事な場所
っぽいですあで
ももうちょっと奥行け
そうこの先がもう本当
にザ白跡の部分行きましょう
かここら辺です
ね
[音楽]
わあんなカシャんって言いませんでした
今聞こえましたみさん聞こえました後ろす
ね僕のカシャンて言いましたよねあほら
ほらほらほら無理無理
無理ふーん海近いんですかここ近いです波
の音は聞こえる
な
[音楽]
うんー古代から伝わるベイブレード
スタジアム
ですここでみんな多分ベゴして遊んでたん
だと思います
うんありますねこういう
のなんか石も使えると高熱出るらしいです
よお願いします
これ誰かこれ置いたんだろうなこういう岩
とかもいいんだろうか悪いんだろうか
分かんないですねえじゃあ海の見える綺麗
なお城だったんでしょうねきっとちょっと
これぐるっと外周回ってみ
ますいや波の音が綺麗だ
な
ああサーベ
か俺なんかすごいすごいですこの木
引っかかってるんかなこれこれ引っかかっ
てそうですよ
ね
はい置いときますね落下すると危ないので
いいことしたから呪わないで
くれこんなに一落としないことありますで
木のカサカサ音ぐらいあっていいじゃない
です
かマジマジで無音ですよです何にも揺れて
ないですもんねもう海辺なのにこんなに風
ないことありますですよね普通もっと吹い
てますよね海の近くに住んでるから分かる
けど普通吹いてますよ夜でも写真撮って
武士
のの映ってて欲しいのでロビンさん写真
撮ってくださいりまし
[音楽]
た
うんこっち側に何か
あるなんすかあれ十字架です
[音楽]
かすげえ結構錆びついてる十字架があり
ますねでもこのなんか錆び方絶対そうです
よねそうですね結構古いすねこれ昔から
ずっとあるんだろうなそれにしてもでかい
な
アマークスロてキリスト教でしたっけ
キリスたんだあそっかそうでした
ねなんか習った気がします確かこっちに
は
うんなんかめっちゃ寒くないですかなんか
ちょっと寒くなってきましたね寒くなって
きました
[音楽]
ねいやいやこの人のお墓だけ木ですよ木
みんなちゃんと石でできてるのにこの人
だけ木です
られてたんすか
ねうわ天草史郎の像
[音楽]
だ祈ってますね多分心霊スポット的には
ここですよね一番やばいってやれてる
ところ
[音楽]
は間違いました寒くてね急に冷え込んでき
ませんでし
た手が冷たいすもんえなんでここで囲まれ
てん
のミニオクコーナーああなんか地盤
が盤が緩んでそうですねなんかこういう
場所危ないので入ってはいけないような
場所っぽいです
ねやめとき
ましょう
うんこれで
もうある程度そのところは見ましたかね
よしちょっと下ります
か割とね見るべきところは見たような気が
し
ます下りましょう
かびさん戦闘でお願いしますちょっと待っ
てくださいいや下りも下りでちょっと
すごい
なあこれすごいっすよマジ怖いくります
[音楽]
ねえっと僕ちどこから来たんでしたっけ
マジで分かんなくなりました
けどえこれ合ってますよなんか怪しいです
なんか怪しいですよね怪しいぞ
これそり立つ壁して戻りますよこっから
いやでも行けるの
かあなんか行けそうです行けそう
です謎の
石持ち帰る言ばこれにします
ロイさんお願いしますハルクじゃなきゃ
無理帰ってきましたかね帰ってあそうです
ね帰ってきましたねなんならなんか一瞬し
ましたね綺麗に周した気がしますそうです
よねいやなんか異様なしきさでしたね本当
にここまで静かとか逆に不気味ですけどで
もなんか1回だけ変な音しましたよねして
ましたねあれなん何の音って言えばいいん
だろう
んなんカシャんって言いませんでし
た今聞こえましたみさん聞こえました後ろ
すね僕のカシャンって言いましたよねあ
ほらほらほらほらさの音じゃなかったです
よねま風が吹いてなかったんでうん編集で
どこまで音が取れてるかわかんないです
けどなんだろうやっぱりすごい人が戦で
なくなってるような場所なので何かしらは
絶対あるんだろうなっていうのとやっぱり
異様な雰囲気ですよね恐ろしいぐらいな
静かな場所ですすごく大ここまでしてる
感じあんまこんな無音の場所ないですよね
うん今まで行ってきた心霊スポットの中で
も静寂な場所っていう印象でしたなんか
すごい印象に残る心霊スポットだったなっ
て思い
[拍手]
[音楽]
ます
すいませんプさん間違いましたちょっと
待って間違いました怖い怖い怖い怖い
間違えちゃいました
ちょっと無理はない上行きますかいやそが
大ですこれ